et oui en fait cette étude montre
également pour la majorité des Français
des opinions politiques divergentes
seraient vraiment un frein à la mise en
couple 55% refuseraient de commencer une
relation et 58% d'avoir une relation
sexuelle avec un partenaire d'un bord
politique opposé non vous êtes le député
de la semaine de la semaine je sais pas
ah bah si c'est l'intervention que vous
avez eu cette semaine c'est
l'intervention sur le fond la plus
intéressante et sur la forme la plus
clivante puisque
Eric Dupond-Moretti ne vous a pas
répondu sur l'insécurité en France
nous on parle pas trop politique en fait
et du coup bah on couche toujours
ensemble voilà merci
et ce qui est formidable c'est que le
lendemain un sénateur cette fois LR lui
pose la même question que vous avec le
même diagnostic avec les mêmes questions
de la même forme et là il répond oui il
a le badge arc républicain je t'ai
trouvé très ras c'est aussi ce qui m'a
aidé dans mon choix j'ai beaucoup aimé
ton attitude
tu as su sans mots en fait me faire
comprendre que tout allait bien tu m'as
serré la main fort pour me dire
t'inquiète on continue tout va bien sur
l'augmentation du SMIC qui était proposé
par la nuque vous avez tous voté contre
macronise droit et vous rassemblement
national est-ce qu'il y a pas un petit
peu de côté là pour le coup mais allez-y
Julien Dole non mais est-ce qu'il y a
pas un double jeu pardon je vous
provoque un peu je trouve cet endroit
mais carrément magique
il y a pas de problème sur l'application
des peines en France
mais si vous m'interrompez à chaque fois
Jack Bauer et il y a un deuxième coureur
qui est aléatoire vous êtes le bienvenu
ici et je remarque que vous n'êtes
absolument pas dans la caricature et ni
dans l'insulte lorsque vous dites que je
suis un militant mais c'est pas bien
c'est pas bien grave vous avez passé
il y a aucun problème vous pouvez dire
que un journaliste est militant ça peut
être en tous les cas quand vous me le
dites moi je le prends comme une insulte
merci Salut je pense que c'est si
vivitatif de d'avoir une nana au volant
parce qu'il y en a de plus en plus et
bientôt ça sera nous qui commanderons le
monde
les jours passent et l'ennui s'installe
jouer à des jeux lire ou regarder la
télé des occupations dont il se lasse et
bien bonjour à tous Nous sommes avec
Simonet zanony le grand chef italien du
George V et aujourd'hui c'est un défi
incroyable pour lui faire des spaghettis
à la tomate ça semble simple mais avec
moi à côté c'est impossible je gâche
tous les plats
le secret de la cuisson c'est de la
cuire toute vivante comme vous les avez
vu là plus elles sont plongées vivantes
dans l'eau bouillante plus le résultat
sera mieux
perdu mon permis de conduire suite à des
bêtises et alors d'aujourd'hui je suis
malheureusement obligé de me déplacer
soit à pied soit en vélo d'accord je
peux vous assurer que ce que moi je vois
sur la route en étant soit piéton soit
vélo cycliste c'est inadmissible
je vais aller lui demander en plus c'est
un français
[Musique]
il est en train de faire ses besoins
je vais peut-être pas y aller tout de
suite
les gens sont devenus cinglés
c'est plus une jungle c'est la loi du
plus fort
attends attends attends
je ferai un selfie avec votre livre sur
la plage alors il faudra me taguer je
vous tagré je me mettrai nue avec ce
livre et je blesserai ce livre dans une
partie incongrue de mon anatomie je
partagerai alors
vous savez Bernanos a dit un jour les
optimistes sont des imbéciles heureux
les pessimistes sont des imbéciles
tristes et ben moi je suis un imbécile
heureux on doit être optimiste matin on
va parler toutes les raisons de penser
que les grossesses et les accouchements
se passent bien faut pas toujours parler
d'hiver à moitié vide
[Musique]